From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
You're way, way, way for the guy.
Hopefully, you're sitting out.
Ready?
Okay. Good morning.
Good morning. Today is August 18, 2013, where in Brooklyn, New York with Dr. John Carlos.
Very honored to be here talking to you today.
My name is David Klein. I am from the Department of History at Virginia Tech University and conducting this interview for the Civil Rights History Project of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Filming this interview is Mr. John Bishop of Media Generation. We also have Elaine Nichols here from the museum and our friend Sonom is also joining us today.
I think that's everything. I want to thank you very much Dr. Carlos for being part of this project.
It's my honor. I mean, this is a very prestigious interview and I'm just honored to be a part of it.
Well, we're very grateful and honored that you've agreed to join us.
Thank you.
Great. What I'd like to do is just start if you could tell us a little bit about your childhood, where you grew up and really who your people are.
And what sort of influences you may have seen from that background in your later life?
All right. Well, let me just start off by my mom and dad.
My dad was born, I would say probably about 60 years after slavery in Camden, South Carolina.
My mom was born in Cuba, migrated to the United States when she was 17.
I met my dad in New York City. They got married. They had three kids.
Earl, Junior, Andrew, Carlos. Well, actually four kids. I'm sorry, I left my baby sister.
John Carlos and then Hepsy Carlos. We're born and raised on Linux Avenue, New York.
Fortunately for me, I had the great distinction to be raised between the Cotton Club and the Savoy Barroom, probably the two most prestigious night clubs in the world at that particular time.
I had an opportunity to grow up there to learn about how to hustle in front of the Savoy Barroom, to do a little song and dance, entertain the people and receive those silver dollars.
I had a coin at a time for particularly youngsters to have a guy named Fred Astaire to come to me because I was a type of kid.
I didn't have the talent to dance and the same, but I had the time to go collect the money.
What he told me at that particular time was he enjoyed us with and pressed him most of the time that we always gave a good show for the money.
That was something to stay with me throughout my career as a public figure in the world of sports to make sure that I gave the people a very good show for the money.
I began to develop in Harlem and wide-eyed, I would look and see what was going on.
At that particular time, I noticed at a very young age that they had a thing called White Flight.
It appeared that all the white folks had a meeting at night and decided that we were going to just move out of Harlem because they all started moving to the suburbs and left Harlem primarily for black people.
What years were these?
I was born June 5, 1945. So I would say roughly eight years, nine years into my life, these things started taking place.
I recall actually my father while I was leaving and my father pretty much told me that it was difficult for white folks to accept the fact that most of the domesticated workers that was there to clean the house
would have you would start to move into the apartment buildings and live as next door neighbors.
So I guess a lot of them felt like we can't have this and they decided to leave.
In retrospect, now he in 2013, if you would go back to Harlem, many of the ancestors of those white individuals that moved out have moved back into Harlem.
It doesn't disappear that way in Harlem is happening all over the United States.
But in any case, I continue to grow in New York. I got a chance to experience what the drug scene was.
When I was a kid, the drug of choice for many individuals was a thing called King Kong. King Kong was a bootleg liquor.
It was almost if I were to put that parallel with something modern times, I would say King Kong was like PCP.
A lot of these individuals would drink this bootleg liquor and they would go to the roof and actually take off like they could fly and jump to their death.
And then overnight King Kong left and this thing called Heron came in, smack mud or whatever you get to call it.
And that's when I noticed that family started to disintegrate.
When I say disintegrate, I mean explode in terms of all of the love and affection and the harmony that they had in the household just dissolved.
Because at that particular time, there used to be a unit, a family unit.
To the point where all families got together between 5'30 and 6'o'clock to have dinner, to have discussion as to what happened in school, did you do your homework?
How did you make out of your science project? All of these things were taking place.
And then when the drugs came in, it just disillusioned a lot of the fathers.
Many of the fathers became, as I call them, missing an action because they stopped coming home.
They were sprung on those drugs and left pretty much the families to be raised by the mothers.
Mothers tried and do the best they could.
A lot of them at that particular time had 3 or 4 or 5 kids.
And then for the mom to try and raise those kids by themselves, it put a lot of unnecessary pressure on them.
Some of them started to chip around with the drugs themselves. Some of them went to alcohol.
But the bottom line was it was very difficult for them to survive economically.
If you looked at that particular time for a black family in the United States, jointly, if they made $15,000, there was a top of the line.
So when the fathers left, that cut income considerably.
So then when you looked in there, closet, there was no clothes. You looked in the ice box. There was no food.
There was anything that they had was a hand down from maybe brother that was 4 or 5 years older than them. They just would hand the clothes down.
I began to look around in terms of what role could I play, what could I do?
Did your family hang together during this period?
My mother and father was strong as the rocket you brought to. My father was a shoemaker. My father was a veteran from the First World War.
He had an entrepreneurial type of mind where he was his own man and he set up his own business and did quite well.
My mother came in pretty much as a domesticated worker as well.
I remember when we were young kids, my mother would take my myself from our brother at times when she used to go and clean the abortion offices, all through a Harlem.
You know, going and cleaning the after-birth.
And I remember I used to go snooping around just to look and see what was going on.
And I saw some things in there that maybe I shouldn't have saw at that particular age.
Well, you know, I went on to realize that I don't want to go into detail about it.
But I would say with the drug trade, the deputate at the time, there was a professional type of drugs that some of these professional doctors had in the office where professional people used these drugs like entertainers,
doctors, lawyers, or what have you. And then there was a street drug that I mentioned earlier that the heroin I was out just open for just the everyday people in the street.
But I began to look around as I said to see what my niche was. What could I do to try and make things better for my peers, you know, the standard of life that they had to bring them up to, at least standard that we had in my household.
And I saw a guy on TV that I was very impressed with, a white fella.
He used to run around in a green suit and had a funny looking hat with a fella sticking out it. And they call this guy Robin Hood.
And I began to look at Robin Hood in terms of, wow, this is a guy that I want to image myself as.
I got it had no fear in terms of the authority figures because it appeared to me that Robin Hood split the pee in half so to speak and made it clear to himself.
There was two laws of the land. There was God's law and there was man's law. And he made it clear that he wasn't concerned about man's law.
He was concerned about God's law. And he did his job. And when I say man's law, I'm talking about like the sheriff nodding him, you know, the way they presented Robin Hood.
And I like the way he carried himself. So then I began to look at what was happening in the freight trains just like this.
This culture of the carriage would come through nodding him far.
Well, the Yankee Stadium in the freight jobs over there was nodding him far for John Carlos.
And I remember going over there with a couple of my buddies and told him we was going to investigate boys coming in on the trains.
And at that particular time they were bringing in much food. They had the frozen freight trains coming out with succotash and starting to develop the frozen food products.
They had textiles that was coming through. And my other two was to go and capture these goods, you might say.
And I remember my buddies telling me, man, we're going to have fat pockets. And I said, no, this is not for us. This is for the people in the community that don't have.
You know, and a lot of them that I was talking to at that particular time, they wasn't doing as well as the individuals that I was talking about.
So it was self-serving for them to stock up their houses with clothes and food and so forth as well.
And at the same time, I had to remind myself that my father, my mother, was starch Americans.
I mean, when I say Americans, I mean to the hill that my father served in the First World War.
He was proud of his service in the war. My mother was, you know, a farmer coming to the United States and proud to be an American citizen and just believed in doing things the right way.
So when I'm breaking the law by hitting these freight trains and so forth, they were more concerned about mans law.
And I was more concerned about God's law, but yet still I still had love, respect for my parents, not to let my father know what I was doing and to safeguard myself,
to make sure they didn't get back to my father. That I was breaking into these freight trains.
As I began to get older, I heard about this guy swimming the English Channel.
At that particular time, radio was our TV. We used to listen to Johnny Dalland, Dick Trace, you know, all these guys on the radio.
And I heard them mention this guy swimming the English Channel.
Yeah, as I stated, I didn't know what the English Channel was. I knew that he was in the water.
I knew that I was probably the best bathtub swimmer in Harlem. I would swim quite a bit in the Harlem River, lost quite a few friends in the Harlem River.
But you ever swimming in an organized swimming pool?
No, I never got a chance to swim in a pool, but I developed this thought in my mind that I was going to swim the English Channel.
And I remember asking my father, said, pop the U-swimming. He said, yes, son, just like a rock straight to the bottom.
But I asked him, I said, daddy, if they swim in the English Channel, did they swim with a knife in their mouth? What about the sharks?
I said, and when they have to go to the bathroom, how do they go to the bathroom if they swim in?
You know, because I never knew that they'd come out of the water and do what they had to do, and they'd drop back and water and they carry on.
But I had the mind said that I was inquisitive enough that I wanted to know how you do this, how they set the tide to a compass to go.
What did they get, daddy? Did they get a trophy? Did they get money? Did they get recognition? And he told me, say, son, they get it all.
So he told me he would go and research about the sharks and the whole nine yards, and he would get back to me.
Well, in the meantime, when he went to do that, they came back on the radio again and they started talking about the Olympic Games.
And, daddy, what's the Olympic Games? Well, he said, son, that's when all the great nations come together and they bring their best athletes together.
He said, it's like war games to see who's more physical and more mentally fit to put their best foot forward.
And I said to him, I said, well, daddy, did they have swimming? He said, yes.
I said, well, daddy, did they ever have a black swimmer to represent the United States? And he said, no, son.
And I said, well, daddy, I'm going to be the first black to represent America as a swimmer.
And I developed this in my mind and my heart. And this is something that I really want to do.
And one day, my father, I guess maybe I've gone maybe 10 months a year.
And my father saw that I picked this thing up in my mind and my heart was running with it.
And he said to me, he said, son, we need to have a talk.
And I can look at the expression in his face like it was a painful thing in this talk that we was going to have.
And he was going to have to give me. And I said, what's that, daddy? And he said to me, he said, son, he said, you're going to have to, you know, get rid of that thought about you going to your Olympics as a swimmer.
Why, daddy, what do you mean? He said, well, son, my understanding of the swimmer has to swim three, four times a day, train. Where would you train?
He said to me, he said, you can't go to the Harlem River and train. You lose your friends every summer.
He said, you can't go to colonial pool. That was the public pool where the black kids go to every day.
So you can't go there. People too many people trying to cook love.
You can't go to the ocean. The water is too rough. And I'm saying to him, son, what daddy? I'm joined a club.
And he said, oh, and you can't join a club. And I said, what daddy? We can't afford it. He said, oh, no, we can afford it.
Well, why can't I join? And then he put his hand on like that and he rubbed his hand. And when he did it, I thought he had a bug bite or something.
And he said, no, son, because of the color of your skin.
And before I could die just that and say, because of the color of my skin, there was another pool pool up there, not too far from the other born ballroom where my commercial assassinated called high-bridge pool.
And that was the white area at that particular time. And my father mentioned to me and my father didn't go into pool that much.
But he knew what was going on. And he said to me, he said, son, he said, when you and your friends work the high-bridge pool and you jump into the water, what happened?
And you know, just seconds, you flash back in your mind and you remember, as soon as you hit the water, all the white mothers would jump up and call their kids, Bobby, Billy, Ricky, Betty, Judy, get out the water.
Get out the water, get out the water, hurry up. And it was very complexing for me for the simple reason that in one sense they didn't want to be me.
They didn't want their kids like someone's going to roll off me onto them. And in another sense, they was putting all sorts of lotion on them, laying in the sun, trying to get look like me.
So I was really confused about the whole scenario. And then my father said to me, he said, son, let me ask you this question, are you going to quit?
And I said to him, I said, no, Danny, I'll find another way. Well, by working into those freight trains and showing you how God worked, that was my vehicle to track and feel.
Because we had two detectives in Harlem. I missed the Lester and Mr. Bryant. They were out of a 32nd precinct right there in 135th Street.
They knew my father because my father used to have the poker game on weekends with baseball players, Jackie Robinson, all those people who didn't even play, they would all come together.
And I remember my father having a conversation with those two detectives. And they were telling my father that there's been some break-ins over the freight yards and they think I had something to do with it.
And I was telling my dad that you need to talk to John. And my father stopped them. He actually put his hand up saying, nah, you need to talk to him.
And in that particular time, I was over McCun兵 Park at a PL track meet. And I went over there to run the track meet. I was over there to get some new converse sneakers.
And all the kids had new converse sneakers. And my father was a shoe maker. So I didn't get a chance to get the new shoes. My old man would make shoes.
So in order for me to get some converse, I would have to go over there because the kids that were running, they would take their new sneakers and so forth and put in their pants and roll them up.
Well, me and my buddies never had no new sneakers. So we would go over there and take our old shoes and leave the shoes and take their sneakers.
So when he came that particular day, they'd circle the whole park and had cop cars around the park and they came in and they found me and I was with two of my buddies and they told my buddies, go sit up against the fence.
And they took me into the infield of the track. And Mr. Luster is about six feet and Mr. Brown was about six seven. Mr. Brown was a big guy.
Are these African-American detectives? Yes, sir.
And Mr. Brown said to me, Mr. Luster had something to tell you. Mr. Luster said to me, he said, let me tell you something, Johnny, it's been some break ins.
And we think we know who's doing it. And then it leaned down into my face real close and said, we can't do anything until we catch him.
And we're going to catch him. And then he said, but I have something else I want to tell you. And I looked at him and said, what's that? And he said, you have a talent.
I have a talent. What talent do I have? And he said, you as a runner because the police chase from the Bronx over into Holland River houses.
They catch some of my partners, but they could never catch me. And these were like the Irish police and someone were poorly, but they could roll.
I mean, when I say they could roll, they could run. I mean, gun belt, night stick didn't bother them. They just truck it.
So when he said I was a runner, I kind of smirked like that. And before I could pull myself back, Mr. Brown smacked me upside my head. And when he smacked me head, fingers landed over head.
And that's how big his hands were. And he said, don't you disrespect Mr. Lester. I said, Mr. Brown, I'm not disrespecting him.
I said, but he said that I'm a runner. Everybody in neighborhood runs. And when I said that I had something in mind, specifically based on an incident that happened with my mother, my mother began the working BWH through at night.
And I recall my mother going out one night to work. And I guess about an hour she came back and I stuck. I was all torn and she legs was bleeding. And kid came up and grabbed her purse.
And I guess she was holding onto the person. He drugged down. Well, she got back up and she came home. And you're quite naturally all the men, me, my brother, my father, everybody was upset.
And my mother, she saw it saw it right. We get some a cure cone and we put it under some bandage. And then she held up her purse. She said, but I got my purse back. So when I'm talking about as a runner, I'm saying my mother's a runner. Everybody in the neighborhood is a runner. And they told me, Sonata Johnny, you're special.
And they gave me a number to the New York Pioneer Club to ask me to call a guy by the name of Joe Yancy. He was the head master. You might say, of the track program.
And I went down there. It was a, it was a new experience for me. How did you at this point? I think I was like 13, 14. And I went in and I didn't have any track gear. I didn't know what track gear was.
I went in. I had some quarter van shoes, some, some jeans. And they asked me where is my gear. And I looked at them and I said, first of all, what's gear? And I said, Mrs. All I had.
He said, what do you run? I said, distant because when I went out to the track that day and Mr. Lesson, Mr. Brown caught a whole of me.
What they told me was get on the track and run until we take the stop. Well, they forgot about me. I'm going to run. I'm going to run. Run at track 50 times.
So when the guy asked me, what do I run? I'm a distance runner. So he told me, he said, well, he had these guys over here. The older guys that were the day they were running. It's like 660s.
Jimmy Brown and guys like that. Frankie Barn. They out there running 660s. And I didn't know what it's 660 was. I didn't know what the fall 40 to 20 put together. You know, 660.
And they were running five of them. Well, they had run one when I got there. And when I was talking to Mr. Yancy and Mr. Levy.
And they told me to go. So I got in there and I started running when I'm down the first two I won. I was beating my soul.
They was doing a new defense mind wasn't I won. The next one I come back to third when I won last one. I'm running and they had something called the beer.
I didn't know what the beer was. And that's total fatigue. I wasn't in shape to doing it. I never trained. I was just running off my natural ability on this last one.
I was just running and I was like they had a sniper on the roof and he just shot me. And I just exploded and fell out.
And I remember them taking me out the army. My partner that was down there. They took me out the army. And we were walking on a 141st Street coming back up to Lennox Avenue.
And I remember when it was helping me and it was cold and snow on the ground. And I remember I was coming back through.
You know, I'm starting to get myself together. And I had one older guy. I said, man, who the hell that kid think he is?
I think he's just going to be able to come out here and run against us and do the things he's doing. And I was kind of like looking at him like, what?
And the other guy said to him, man, I don't know who that kid is. But I think everybody going to know who you who you are soon.
And I remember telling the other guy, say, man, I think I'm ready. We can go back and finish that race now.
And the rest was pretty much like stair step in terms of my career because they begin to see me running the meats in high school.
I noticed that a lot of guys didn't have the confidence that I had in my abilities or in their abilities.
I began to excel based on what Mr. Fred Astaire said about giving a good show for the money.
I remember my first competition. We had great cotton sweats, the old great cotton sweats.
And I remember I got a magic marker and I pulled my sweat pants off and I wrote a big J on one of my buttocks and a big C on the other buttocks.
My father said, man, what are you doing? I said, man, I'm putting J C on this. So when they see me jogging, they're going to know this name, J C, J C, J C, Johnny Carlos, Johnny Carlos.
And I went on and built the reputation from high school.
Was there a decent track program at your high school?
Well, we didn't have a track as well. We used to train running the hallways. We'd run the hall and open up the cafeteria doors and run around tables and shoot back down the hall.
And then when we had a time trial to see who was going to go to the Penn Relays, we used to be able to go to Franklin Roosevelt Drive on 96 and First Ave.
We would run the ballwalk there so to speak to see who was going to make the team.
No, we didn't have anything easy. And then I might state that I didn't particularly care for track and feel. I still wanted to be a swimmer.
I went to Frederick Douglass junior high school. And I guess because I was such a gangster kid, you might say.
Because I pretty much ran the school in my time there, my tenure there. And I didn't get a chance to run, excuse me, for the school track program.
And I wanted to go to a certain school high school because they had a swimming program.
But this particular day I think I cut out of school, played hooky that didn't go to school.
And we fill out the paperwork to go to school and they changed my paperwork for me to go to Harron High School on 59th and 10th FAT.
And told me that they had a swim program in the school. And when I found out the day changed the paperwork and I'm giving my paper to someone going to Harron High School, I don't want to go to Harron High School.
Why would you do it? What is this? This is what you put down. And my boys tell me, man, it's going to be all right. They got a great swim program down there. You're going to do well.
When I got down, they didn't have a pool much more swim program. And then I didn't run track for the school.
So why did they send you down there?
Well, they sent me there because they wanted me on the track program. But they didn't have a swim program. And they wouldn't allow me to get on the track program because I wasn't one of the right students, you might say.
I was still in the Doug element. So I never got a chance to run for Harron High School. And then eventually I left Harron High School and transferred to a machine of metal trades on 96th Street.
I'm going to take a little pause here.
This gave me honor. That's yeah, I think it was. It went to the archives because I came back and gave a speech for the Board of Education, for the Prince of Wolves, I guess.
And they went to women said, I'll find out you went to school. Yeah, she dug up some stuff. Board tears in my eyes because I forgot about a lot of the guys. And she made a collage, all the pictures and so forth.
So this is machine metal trades and you transferred there and what what year were you in school?
Man, don't give me the line. But somewhere in high school. Yeah, yeah.
And how did things change once you once you went over there?
Well, this got better for me based on the fact that I some of the guys I knew older guys in my neighborhood had gone to school there and they were involved in the track program.
And I remember we had one group picture. And I was on the team. I was probably one and younger guys on the team, but one of the bigger guys as well.
And we took our first team picture. We had our street pants on and we had the school jersey on and I felt like I was a part of something at that time, you know, to run with guys that I knew and wanted to excel and something.
Once we got out there and gotten involved in the competition, I realized early that those guys didn't have the same awareness of the abilities as I had of my abilities.
You know, they didn't have the confidence to think they can beat a lot of guys. And tracking field when you first start track or feel it's it's a novice novice is individuals that have never won anything.
They have opened individuals they have won a medal. They have won something in the past. And we went in and we went in as novice. And we were sitting on the floor. They bring us all the novice kids out and they sit us on the floor.
And as we were sitting on the floor, the open guys, the ones that had excelled in the past, they were running their races.
You know, I remember looking at my guys and they were like horrified that this man we can never beat these guys. Look how fast y'all. And I remember telling them, say man they only look fast because we're sitting here watching them.
We will be just as good as them when we get out there and run against them. And another thing I noticed that they had songs about boys high, do we Clinton, Rhythmas, they had no songs from me at Machina Metal Traits.
So when we got up and we ran our memo told them I said, if y'all bring me this baton 30 yards and back to the last guy we'll win.
Because I'm going to catch you up without there. And we went on and we broke the record and our heat. And I never forget we went to lunch at the delicatessen store right there on Amsterdam Avenue by the armory.
And we went there and we ate by the time we come back that afternoon to run the finals that created a song about Machina Metal Traits. And I'm nodding them saying man they're singing about us, they're singing about us.
So that was a start of us having a legendary reputation there. And we went on and we won the final. We broke the record again.
But when my legacy started in track and field and the 16th Street Armory I ran extremely well indoors. But that wasn't the racists.
The racists outside after the track meet was over because I would race against all and winners outdoors and actually having an opportunity to say, look man I race you.
And you got all your medals because a lot of the guys they took so much pride in their awards they pinned them on the jacket and medals that I won I used to give them to the girls.
It was a competition that I like it wasn't about the award. If I got an award I got an award because I want the show that I was there. You had to win something to let them know you was there.
If I took 30 it didn't matter. But when I got outside of the armory that's when the real competition started because I would give a guy say man I'm going to give you four call lengths on Beachy by three.
And it was extraordinary because I had as many people outside watching these races as was inside. They didn't even give me give us a formality we had to go through the process indoors.
But everybody was waiting for after the track meet the serious races. I was like street ball taking a break.
Last night I was there and that's all they were talking about. Say Johnny you know we were just little kids but we heard legend we heard legend a lot of the younger guys they never met me and they looking at me like I'm a living legend you know and it kind of like freaky out.
You know you guys looking at you like that and then the head stories that they were saying about your peers that was there with you things that they were saying about me different type of thing.
I never knew what they were saying. I just tried this out last night. But that's what built the legend in John Colors.
Do you remember that song from a scene in the middle trades at all?
No man I can't remember. It wasn't a fling-voin song with something had to do with Marilyn Monroe's chest or something like that.
But it was a strong song. But what I was trying to say relative to me looking at track and feel I begin to go to another level and track and feel like what track and feel really means to me and not so much about me getting start them.
But what I can use track and feel is a springboard too. I begin to realize that the better I'm perfecting my game the better I can speak.
The better I can have a platform to do what I need to do in life because I never forgot about what happened on that exam.
I never forgot about the drugs. I never forgot about the domesticated work. I never forgot about white flight.
And then at the same time I'm starting to learn about prejudices and racism and that kind of thing.
So now I'm really looking at this thing in terms of me being able to use track and feel as a vehicle.
The better I got the more I was able to have a platform to give my message off.
And these days everybody wants to play ball and get out. This is what everyone thinks is the magic ticket.
And those days were sports seen as a ticket out?
You have to look back in those days and look at it for what it was.
When you sit back and think about what was happening back let's say 60, 70, 80 years ago.
It was like this in the area if they had black kids or minority kids and they had white kids while the white part of the town had a swimming pool.
Then in black area never had a swimming pool. People never had a swimming pool. But what they would give us in place is a basketball court.
So when you sit back you think about all the superstar basketball players back in the day, Bill Russell, Elgin Bell and the guys before them.
They became superstars merely because that was what they gave them a post to giving them the standard with all kids,
and then the summer to be in a swimming pool. But they didn't want us in the water. And the same thing fell.
So everybody was doing a thing in terms of let me perfect my game.
But it wasn't my game to say I'm playing basketball because I want to be an NBA star.
I'm playing because I enjoy the game and I'm perfect in my game and I'm good at it.
Now people start to come and look. But then on the same time the people that gave them the puck,
they began to look at them in terms of economic growth and economic gain because now we can take these kids.
Now we didn't know that they was going to build their game like that.
And then you know the Rutgers tournament that they have in New York,
it was so many individual kids that had to become street merchants, hustling in the street,
that had phenomenal basketball talent. The pros wanted them.
They looked at the pros like, man, this is my game. You're going to change my game.
And you can't wave no money. I'm making as much money as you try to offer me.
So that era, they looked at Rutgers and turned to saying, oh, these kids here have a different sense about them.
Like you know when Wilk Chamon came down, Elgin Bella came down,
all of them would go to Rutgers tournament and they had their greatness at bottom.
But they found these raw natural kids had equal greatness.
But you know, still those kids are saying, man, you can't tell me enough of it because that's my rose rice parked over there.
Because they got involved in the street merchantry.
It was all about dollars. But with your dollars, you want to give me dollars to control me in the way I play ball.
Well, my dollars I'm free enough to be my own man and play ball the way I see fit to play ball.
And that's the way I grew. And now, in modern times, things have changed.
Everyone wants to just be focused on the dollar. I don't see nothing about what's happening in my community.
I'm not concerned about my fellow man.
None of those things are taking place now. The bottom line is the almighty dollar.
All the drugs that you see in basketball, football, or baseball, or track and field.
They put that secondary in terms of they should have been moving on this long time ago.
They know the difference in when Hank Aaron and Willie Mays and then was playing ball the post to the modern day ball player.
Now, they knew what Jesse on his dead, Tommy Smith or Liam's or John Collins did, opposed to what these kids are doing now.
But they said, we'll turn our head to it because we're bringing people through the third style.
We make money. We get bigger TV contracts.
All the sponsors want to come in now.
But then you look at sports right now and you say, wow, the sponsorship is not as great anymore.
And tell the Olympics are rolling around. Why is it great anymore?
Because I don't want to sponsor something and then pick up the next day and find out that these guys are using drugs and tonnish my product.
So they're not jumping out there as much anymore.
Anytime they jump out there as the Olympics, like Finns is right now, Mr. Putin, President of Russia.
He's talking about, you know, I don't want gays in the games.
Well, he's ridiculous.
If he thinks that the gays are not involved in society and something is wrong with him.
Now, if they want to get into a moral clause, then my whole line to them is, when you become God and you show me that you're God,
then you can be a moral figure over these individuals.
But tell them, you just like me, you can't step into place of God.
Say, because this person is this way, that person is that way.
They shouldn't be allowed to do this. They shouldn't be allowed to do that.
And then I sit back and look at the Olympic Committee and I say shame on you.
Shame on you because in 1936, Hitler said, I don't want Jews and I don't want blacks on the team.
The Olympic Committee stepped up there and said, oh, wait a minute, Mr. Hitler, you need to take a seat on this.
But when they went to Germany, Hitler still stepped in and they still buckled and gave in to the fact that they took those young Jews, fellers off the team and replaced them because Hitler was against the Jews.
Now, they had the same responsibility to step up to the plate to tell Mr. Putin and I say, God forbid.
And here's a hypothetical statement. If you say in both, it's to come out.
Are any noted figure in the sports world right now, it's to come out and say, I'm gay.
And this is hypothetical. But if this guy said, I'm gay, do you think that the Olympic Committee would let Mr. Putin tell, saying both, that he can't run into Olympic Games because of his sexual preference?
The Olympic Committee would tell Mr. Putin, you better go take a seat somewhere because he's the one that's selling the tickets.
But for them to go and do this and sit on their thumbs and allow him to do this, sub-sert, especially at this day and time.
But these are the issues that we have to deal with and these are the issues that these young athletes are going to have to be confronted with later on down the line.
There's no neutrality in this. You can't say, man, I'm a right-wing defense on this.
I'll see you with something or you'll against it. And if you're not going to take one side of the other, you're going to lose respect of your peers.
You can show that you don't really have respect for yourself when you can't make a decision at a crucial situation such as that.
Did you see the athletes speaking up on this, or do you think they will?
Let me take this. I think the athletes have a lot of concern about these issues.
But I think it's a matter of courage because you have to have courage because people are more concerned not about right, but they're concerned about repercussions.
And they have to throw a repercussion to the win and do what's necessary because when you make a statement, it's not the statement that you make it is not for you.
It's for your kids and your kids, kids and their kids to make it a better world for them coming down the line.
I can't change what happened in 1936. I can't make an immediate change what's going to happen in 2013.
For instance, I couldn't make an immediate change for what happened in 1968. But here we are in 2013. It made a significant change now relative to the way people think.
It's better for my kids now. It's going to be better for their kids now.
These individuals, I can't tell them that you should boycott because I don't agree with the boycott no more.
And the reason I don't agree with the boycott is for two simple reasons.
Because I equated the boycott parallel with an embargo against the nation.
When we put an embargo against the nation, the government don't get hurt. The people of that nation get hurt.
The government is still doing business. They still make money. Now on the other side, the boycott of the Olympic Games.
The Olympic people don't get hurt. Two elements, which are two most important elements, those are the ones that get hurt.
The spectators, because they never get the chances he, the greatest, perform. The athletes get hurt.
Because they train all their lives to perform and show their whiz and they don't have an opportunity.
So what I suggested to them is, hey man, I would suggest that you evaluate the circumstance of which you involved in.
Research the circumstance which you involved in. Search your soul and search your moral fiber to see whether you have conviction enough to bring your courage up.
I say, I'm going to do with floats my boat. It's not about what John Collins told him to do. It's not about me telling him this is my history.
It's about whether you have enough in you to search out and find or just causing these things and stand fast to which you believe in.
Whatever floats they boat. That's what they're going to have to do because that's what they're going to have to live with.
I want to go back and catch up with the chronology. Let me ask you just one question first since we're on.
We're back.
And this goes to what you were saying about the athletes, getting the chance to show their wares.
But you all in 68, you were willing to not run that year. Right?
Because of wanting to make a statement and what you believed in.
How difficult was that? I think you've got that.
Well, it wasn't difficult for me at all. It wasn't difficult for me at all because I leave a way to the Olympic Games as a track meet.
You haven't met in many track meets. But the bottom line is whether we can make a statement for society.
I feel like you know, meadows are great.
What meadows are nowhere near close to what life is all about.
Now, for instance, you know, a lot of people was upset with Jimmy Carter when Jimmy Carter boycotted against the Russians and the Olympics.
Oh, he shouldn't have did it. He shouldn't have did it. But Jimmy Carter's philosophy was that I feel that life is far more valuable than Olympic medals.
Only difference that with me in that 45-year span is I began to look at who is the sacrificial lambs.
The athletes and the ones that hurt the spectators and the ones that hurt and the powers to be that we really the one that we try to get their attention to had them,
to have some compassion and consideration to change their ways. They're still making their money.
The Liberal Committee still selling sponsorship. They still sign a multi-million dollar contract for TV rights.
They still selling popcorn and crack rejects and hot dogs and Coca-Cola's in every form.
When you boycott the games, you've forgotten cause.
Just by the grace of God, well, I said, what happened to us in Mexico City was a spiritual thing. God stepped in.
Everything fell right. Like I stated earlier, this is the first time that games televised universal in this planet.
This is the first time the game was televised in color. This is the first time the game was held in a thorough-world nation.
All of these things culminated with happening on that victory stand at that time.
And I can go father to tell you when I was a kid on that same street I was telling you Lennox have, when I was seven, eight years old, God gave me a vision and showed me in a arena.
I didn't know what the stadium was. I didn't know what the podium was. I was on a box.
And I went to wave and I'm right handed. When I went to wave to the people, I put my left hand up the wave.
And before I can get my hand up high, my hand was by the same way it was with that glove.
And I went to wave to the people and it changed like from joy. Everybody was jippy-kaiyenne. When I first went out there, that's why I went to wave.
Because I don't know me at the minute. And nobody out here but me. There must be a plot for me.
And when I went the wave, it's like somebody snapped their finger and all the joy and happiness turned into anangren, venom, and hatred.
And that's exactly what happened 15 years on that victory stand in Mexico City.
Now, why did God show it to me? I'm humble that he reached out into the beaches of the world and picked up a grain of sand and threw it on the table with my name.
And they said, you have to do this. I didn't tell them guys that I was trying to wake up to about the boycott you have to do this.
All I say, man, let's put the cards on the table, man, and you make it a vested evaluation as to what this is all about and you make a decision.
And they said, you should say we're going to the games. I didn't have the right to tell them you can't go to the games.
You're training all your life. If you feel like it's one point for you to go, go.
But in retrospect, now they sit back and they would just say, now who was right?
Because all the time that I was going through trials and tribulations or Tommy Smith was going through trials and tribulations or peed and no more was going through trials and tribulations, there was jippy-kaiyenne.
We made the wrong move. They made a bad move. They should have never did what they did.
Now we didn't dwell in the storm. Now here are kids. Come back and talk to my, oh man, I think those statues that they built the San Jose State, I should have a brick dining with my name on it.
Why should you have a brick with you on that? Well, we all ran together. If that statue had me breaking the tape passing the baton,
I would be glad to have a brick with your name on it. I said, but that statue depicts something greater than athletics.
You could have been a part of it. I don't understand. See, and then I said, well, let's take this hypothetical trip again.
You want to roll me? Let's have some discussion about this. And this is for anybody out there in the audience right now. This is something for you to wait.
Some of the approaches you will tell you say you can make a difference in society. You have to sacrifice in order to make this difference.
You didn't want to do anything and you thought that you made the right decision. And here we are 40 years later things turn around and you think that, hey, I should jump on the bandwagon because I was in that era, would you?
Well, let's go on this train. What are we getting on a train for? We getting on this train to have some dialogue. Make you understand why I think a boycott is necessary to make me understand why you feel necessary for you to go to these games.
So we have a consensus that we're going to talk about this. Yeah, let's get on the train. Let's roll. Now we getting on this train. And it's just like soldiers going to the first wall wall.
Everybody outside with a American flag and they singing God bless America and they got their hearts and their heart tears in the eyes.
And we're on the train having this discussion, but as a train rolling all down the line, they waving the flag and singing the song.
And then somebody says, you know, man, I have a better understanding now why is it necessary for me to make a statement.
I'm not saying that I'm a boycott. All I'm saying to you is that I understand. Oh, you understand? You mean we have a consensus that we understand why it's necessary.
Now I'm reaching for the red lever. You know what the red lever is in the train. I'm stopping the train. What are you pulling the train? The lever fall.
Okay, we're back. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. So what are we pulling the lever for? We're pulling the lever man to stop the train because if we ever get consensus, the consensus don't mean not if it's just a consensus that we know about.
We have to stop the train to put the banners on the side of the train to let the world know that we have a consensus about the pros and cons of this boycott.
That potentially we might pull it together to do this. Now as a train begins to roll after we get the banners on, all of those people that's out there singing God bless America, they no longer did.
Because they don't like the fact that we talking about we going boycott the limited. They don't like the fact that we talk about we're not going to represent America.
That's like the soldier say I'm not going to war for you. We don't like the fact that you say you're not going to war.
So okay, we rolling. Now in the place of those people that was out there, they're no longer there, but you know what took their place?
Bombs and missiles and fire bombs coming to the train that the trains on fire smoke may have.
And now here 45 years later you come back and tell me you deserve a brick. Well if you deserve a brick step on up here, I need you to do something for me.
What's that John? Open up your shirt. Pull up your pants like roll up your sleeve. What are you looking for?
Well, man, I'm looking for burns. If you don't have burns on your body, such as Mr. Smith or such as Mr. Norman or such as John Colors, then that means when things got hot, you bailed.
And that's exactly what happened. And you know what came to my mind from that point is that individuals get locked up in the fact that I'm afraid to offend my oppressor.
Those individuals that got their foot on their neck are holding up from getting fed education or fair housing or fair health care. They're the oppressors, but I know you wrong, but I'm afraid to offend you because you might get mad.
Well, shit, John Colors don't care about what you get mad because I'm a die one day anyway. I might as well die standing on my feet and swallowed in the mud.
And they have to understand that I'm a loving guy, but yet and still I was raised to be responsible and I'm being responsible to no one else to my kids and to the kids.
Let me ask you to talk about influences. You talked a little bit about your family, maybe a little bit more about your parents, but also, you know, we're talking about your days and track and high school and all.
And I know you got to listen to and get to know a little bit, Mr. Malcolm X. If you could talk about. Yes, that him. Well, let's go a little bit deeper than Malcolm X.
Okay. When I was a kid, I was looking for religion. Why was I looking for religion because there was a lot of voice in my life. You know, a lot of things I'm thinking about did just didn't have answers.
So I'm seeking out answers. So I found God. I found religion and I found a church called Abyssinia Baptist Church. And I told my mother and father my brother about it and we decided that we was going to go to Abyssinia Baptist Church.
We get to the church and we see Adam Clayton Powell senior Adam Clayton Powell senior look like my father.
But then one day we went to church and Adam Clayton Powell senior was sick and he came out to the poor pit and he said, I'm not doing well.
I have a fever. I'm not going to preach the sermon today. I'm going to let my son preach the sermon.
And I'm asking my father to say, who is this son daddy? And I see this white fella over there putting on the road. My father pointed there he is there.
And I say, where? He said, God putting the road one. I said, daddy, that's not his son. That's a white man. He said, no son, that's his son.
That's Adam Clayton Powell junior. And when he got up there and preached and wasn't about the color of his skin, it was about the content of his heart and his spirit and his mind based on what he was preaching.
And then the thing that he said, after which was probably more profound than me is to tell the people to keep the faith.
That's something that was like every day because he felt the pain and he knew the hell that people was going through.
People of color, not just handing that things, but around the world. And at the same time, I remember my father telling me years ago, he's not passing.
And I'm going to look like passing what daddy's and he said, he's not passing to be a white man. And I remember looking at my father and I said, daddy, you tell me that people ashamed of who they are that they would try and be somebody else.
And he said to me, he said, no son, he said, they're not ashamed, although some of them might be a little overzealous. I know it overzealous man.
So he says to me, he says son, he says, not today don't want to be black. On the other side of the street, he said, well white folks live, that standard life is better.
If they can go and have a better standard life, then they cross over if their skin is fear skinned, that they can pass as being a white man to have a better standard life.
And you know what I equated that to? It's not that people want to leave Cuba and risk their lives coming across the water, leave Haiti, risk their lives coming across the water and force the projection.
If Cuba is bad or Haiti is bad, they leave in their country because they think they country or they present it as bad.
They leave in their country and risking their lives for the same reason those white, young, light, skinned, skinned individuals cross the line.
It's because they want a better standard life. And any man, irregard, so what your ethnic background is, she want to have a better standard life for their families.
So I learned these things very early. So I got a whole, I haven't taken Paul and I put him in my system.
There was another guy, Marcus Govy. I began to study Marcus Govy because they used to have Marcus Govy parade up and down New York and Harlem.
And my brother used to be one of the tumble that's flipping the stick in the air in the whole nine yards and I used to look at him.
But then I began to look away from him and began to look at the symbols that they had behind him and the parade.
And then I'm going to start, who is this guy Marcus Govy? And what is Marcus Govy noted for? Marcus Govy got ships and he told black people in America say, hey man, I got these ships.
Get on the ships. Let's go back to Africa so you can meet up with yourself. You can find out who you are. And retrospect when we look at that today, that's the biggest flaw that black people have.
We still in 2013 don't know who the hell we are as eraser people. So that's one of our biggest problems now with the drug scene with the, the 15th and wrap music and this respect for seniors.
And a whole nine yards based on the fact that we've been hidden from ourselves. So okay, so I study Marcus. Paul Roberson.
I study Paul Roberson. And that's one of my greatest heroes because this man sacrificed everything for the mayor fact that he had everything.
He's a Burr-Tone singer. He's a Rhodes scholar. He's an entertainer. He's a movie star. He had everything going for him. All he had to do was zip his lip. But it wasn't about him.
He said, man, it's about my past. It's about my neighborhood. It's about my community. It's about those that doesn't have what I had that can't speak for themselves. So the same thing that I did, he did.
He used to tell us that he had as a springboard for him to be a voice for people. They call him a communist. They call me a communist in 1968. The same reason. And you know why they call me a communist? Because I had the left arm opposed to the right arm.
But it didn't stop me to determine from what the truth is and where I need to go. It didn't stop him. I mean, they took his past forward away from him. They did the tremendous amount of things to him. But it didn't break his spirit in terms of where he was going.
Then I hear as a young individual on the radio one more time. This guy speaking on the radio. And I'm saying, wow, this is profound. Who is this guy?
Well, they say his name is Mark. Oh, man, I love what he said because I heard nobody outside my father speak the way he's speaking. Now here's somebody. My father didn't have no corner where he can go get on the box that speaks to the community. But he did speak truth in the house.
Now, here's a guy on the radio speaking for the world of here. Who is he?
Marka Max. Name Marka Max. I didn't know about the Muslim set. His name is X.
Then he said he was coming to head the mosque on a hundred and sixteen street. Now, hundred sixteen street at that time was a drug and festive. That's probably why they put the mosque there to try and clean up some of that.
And when he went down there, I remember telling my father, say, daddy, I'm going down a hundred sixteen street to hear Marka Max.
My father said, some of you go down there. Don't you get in no trouble. Now, daddy, I ain't looking for no trouble. I'm going to hear him.
Now, I remember going down there and sitting in the front row the first time and listening to him and all. When I went in there, the first thing that blew me away is because when I went in there, just like I was looking for Adam Clayton Powell, who is Marka Max? Which one is Marka Max?
Over there. Marka Max was a fair skin dude, light skin. And I'm looking at him and said, man, I can't be Marka Max. This guy is blowing too black to for him to be Marka Max.
Showed enough when he started talking my lip fell open. It was him. And I'm sitting this close to him and listening to him.
And I can just feel the blood just running through my body, man. I couldn't sit still. I was just with excitement for me to be there and see somebody live that I could touch that was talking like that.
Because the way he was talking is the way I was feeling because I'm seeing what's happening in my community. And at the same time, when you see these things, man, it's the difference when you see them and your peers don't see them. They're still in the basketball.
When we were younger, they're still in the spin in the bottle. They're still in the playing post office with the girls. And I'm looking at it. It's something deeper than that.
I don't have time to spin the bottle and play the post office and jump in Jackson and loadies and all. I'm trying to get to the meat of things.
Yeah, he is talking the exact same way I was feeling. So then I started to go back. I think the second and third time I went there and asked him, I waited around and I said, tell him I said, Miss Dex, is that possible?
I can go with you from this location to your next location. And he looked at me and he smiled. I never forget he had a big dimple in his chin. And he says to me, he says, why do you want to go with me?
And say, because I want to learn, I want to ask you questions. And he liked my answer. And he said, yes, she didn't come with me. He said, if you can keep up.
I didn't know what he meant. Keep up. And so it dawned on me when I was walking with him was like walking my two older brothers because they were tall and with fast walking.
I used to have to jog to keep up with them. But with my command, the jog to keep up with him, just the same. But I was learning a lot from him. And I had built the bond with him. And when Dr. When my my comments got killed at the auto bomb bar room.
I was supposed to be there that Sunday. And we decided, me and some of the guys that was with machine metal trades on the track team that I was going to go try and get my driver's license that Monday.
And we took a road trip and drove up the Buffalo New York, not Buffalo, but a beer mountain. And we passed by West Point. And just as we passed by West Point, it came on the news that Malcolm X was shot.
Man, we turned around. We shot back to the hospital. By the time we got back to the hospital, he was gone. And everybody was milling around. And I could tell you, man, probably better part of 40 years, that 40 years, but 20 years of my life.
I felt real bad. It felt like if I was in the auto bomb bar room that day, I could have did something to prevent him from dying.
It took 20 years for me to die just that Malcolm X was born to this world to die that day.
I was born into this world to be on that victory stand in Mexico. Certain individuals are born to be here to do certain things like that young kid, trade bond mod.
He was born to die that day to try and wake society up. And just to be in that fold, man, just to be there, you humbled when you really figured out you began to look and say, you know, like Martin wanted to live too.
When I was sad to meet with Martin Luther King, and after me was over in the meeting the consensus of the meeting was he wanted to be supportive of the Olympic boycott.
You know, and that's a heavy thing. You know, you involved in the civil rights movement. You know, you know, after you get involved in the boycott.
And after the meeting I asked him, I said to him, I said, I said, Mr. King, if you ever play any sports, then he gave me a little smart remark like I can't play pool.
And I remember when he came out of that room in the hotel, I remember sitting there and I'm looking at luminaries that was dead that we seen on TV.
But I still didn't put the dots together, think that I'm going to be in the presence of Dr. Martin Luther King.
My household, Dr. King was like God's first lieutenant that he sent in. That's the way we was raised, believed it's.
And man, I'm sitting there. And when that door opened and Dr. King walked out, like I was like living like wow.
And he could see that I was like out of my element, probably me and some other people that was there too.
If Dr. King wanted to be a deaf, jam, kind, comedian, he could have been that because he cracked some jokes.
He saw and he cracked jokes, man, he loosened everybody up. Then we got an immediate conversation.
He said that he didn't want to be the number one figure for the Olympic boycott.
He wanted Harry Edwards to do that, but he wanted to be second in command.
And when he come back from Memphis, he's going to go full blown.
Can we just back a minute and say what that meeting was?
The meeting was...
And who Harry Edwards?
The Harry Edwards, Professor Harry Edwards was the organiser he had ever felt about a name of Ken Knows.
They were the organiser for the potential Olympic boycott of the 1960 Olympics.
Tommy Smith had made a statement in Japan about a possible boycott.
And I think that came off the top of his head.
It kind of snowballed to the point where people started talking about it.
And I think it clicked and resonated with Dr. Edwards, Professor Edwards and Professor Knows.
And then they started putting together the organiser.
And when they did this, I was off the scene.
I wasn't on the scene.
And I was going to school at East Texas State dealing with my own enclosed racism.
And when they started becoming public, then I heard about what was happening in the sound of the thing with the potential boycott.
So I'm stepping up speaking and fighting the racial issues there at East Texas State University.
Let's just catch up chronologically and then we'll get to that meeting.
Okay, you take a break.
Yeah.
And then we're back.
Great.
So could you just tell us a little bit how you ended up at East Texas and what you faced when you were there?
As I stated earlier, I was married in my senior year in high school.
We had petitioned to get an apartment in the city housing project.
I was running track at the time and I was running a track meet in New Jersey.
It was a guy named Pete Peterson, I think.
He was a student at East Texas State University and he saw me run.
And he said, man, you think about going to college?
And I said, not really.
And he said to me, he said, listen.
He said, I think I can get you a scholarship.
And he said, I'm going to give you a name and number two is Coach.
And I guess he saw some talent probably more than I took for granted.
I'm just doing my thing.
And the coach called me and said, listen, he said, you know, I liked off of you a scholarship.
And you know, you can come down.
It's nice.
It's nice down here.
It's no prejudice or anything.
You know, when you go the way to the track meet all the wives and the kids going to bus to the track meet,
you get a chance for ride horses the whole nine yards.
Something to myself, I said, wow, that might be nice.
You know, you get a chance to get my daughter because I own this daughter was born.
And I said, it might be nice to get my daughter a chance to grow up outside of the city.
It might be a nice situation.
So I said, okay.
And at the same time, I was supposed to leave to go to East Texas State.
I got a notification from New York City Hall and authority that we was accepted to get an apartment in the project.
You know, you think, I'm thinking economics, then I'm saying, if I got an apartment, my rent will be as a sealant to my rent.
And you know, I'll be able to sustain myself.
Then the scholarship came.
So the decision I had to make, you know, as to what I was going to go to East Texas State,
or what I was going to just stay and work in New York and be satisfied with the guy that gave me the terms of having that apartment in the project.
But you wouldn't be running if you took that.
Oh, well, I can run for the clubs and so forth.
So I had some dialogue with my wife and I was telling her, well, you know, it might be nice, you know, for a baby to get a chance to grow up outside of the city.
And I was telling her, I said, well, if we're going to go, I'll go down and I'll check the turf, I'll sort of speak.
And my wife told me she said, no, if you go, we go, we're a family.
So I ain't going to argue with that. It's the fact. So I said, okay, we'll go.
And it was a fellow by the name of Dennis Dice, he was Jamaican.
American Jamaican. I guess he was born Jamaican. Left when he was young.
Okay. Dennis Dice.
Okay. So yes.
Hold on.
We're still rolling.
Okay. Dennis Dice.
Yes. So Dennis Dice was a young guy. You know, we grew up together, but we didn't grow up together, but we used to run track in New York together.
And he was young, had his wife and young daughter as well.
And we were going down there.
And Dennis had a different agenda. Dennis was born, I think, in Jamaica.
He used to make statements, but he wasn't black. He was Jamaican.
And Dennis was getting confused. His ethnicity with his nationality.
And I was trying to make him understand. He was a darker skin, black person.
And I was trying to make him understand. I mean, he said, you're not black. You're Jamaican.
And the bottom line is, if the police was a kick down the door right now, he's going to probably whip you up more than me, just based on the texture of your skin.
So don't say that you're not black. You are black.
So when we got down to Texas, you know, we was buddy buddy. We were going to have each other's back when we got down there and the great divide came.
You know, he looked at the coaches and said, let me slide up under the coach and be the coaches.
I don't want to say boy, but I don't know other ways to say it. You know, that's what it was.
And I saw that right away. But even greater than that, when I landed in Dallas, Fort Worth, and there was nowhere near the monstrosity airport that they had today.
There was a little box, you know, like box calls almost. And I remember seeing the bronze statue, the Texas Ranger bronze statue in there.
I had somewhere in the New Airport, you still see it. But when I looked at right at the statue, I saw a sign say, white's only.
It was the restroom. And then I saw another sign say colors.
It didn't say colors only, just colors. And anybody else wanted to go in there. But then I began to notice that the white restroom was pristine.
Man, it was clean. You know, like you could cook eggs on the floor. It was so clean.
And then the colored restroom, man, it had water running, toilet paper on the floor, and gnats and flies.
I'm looking then, I'm looking at the water fountain airport. You couldn't go there. It was white's only. And didn't have no black water fountain.
And then the other just whites only, like whatever you need some water. And then when the coach came, my name changed from John Coloss to boy.
And I was really offended then because I was a young man at the time. But what offended me is because I had my daughter with me.
And my wife with me, and he called me boy, and I'm telling them I said coach, my name is John Coloss. My name is boy.
And then he went so far to use this word nigg-ruh. And he said it fast. And I thought he was saying nigg-ruh.
And I remember that he is raising up on my neck. And I looked at him, I said, what you saying? What you call me? And my wife was kind of like pulling my arm.
No, baby, he didn't say that. He said something else. And I remember telling him, I said, well, he said he damn close. He better be careful.
And from that point on, I knew I was going to have problems. And I was always the type of individuals to take my parents into account in terms of their economic base.
They didn't have the money for me to pick up the phone. I'm sure if I'd have called and said, daddy, I made a mistake. I needed to get out of here. They would do what they had to do to get me back to it.
But I wouldn't do it. I said, well, we don't tough it out. And when I got in town, I realized that the school had just become integrated possibly a year, maybe two years before I got there.
So, you know, like as I stated earlier, you know, we've been supposed to be emancipated for 150 years. And we still just above being a slave. You know, in a lot of instances.
And down there, it was pretty much that same way. Although they said we were fully integrated school, they still had the old slave master attitude.
I remember when my daughter was outside playing one time and with little white kid. And you know, kids don't know them. But no race. They just kids having fun.
And the father must have looked out the window and saw his daughter playing my daughter. And he went and he screamed in his daughter and screamed in my daughter and used the N word again and telling the daughter, I don't know once you playing with this little.
Now, my daughter didn't know what it said, but what it meant no more than I knew what it meant. I had an experience like that one time my great uncle in New York. She didn't know what that word meant.
It was just a tone and the way the man confronted her. It scared it. It came to the house crying. And I asked her what happened. And she said, man, start hollering and screaming and telling her daughter don't play with her.
And I went outside and tried to get out of line with me. And I remember getting in this guy's face and in the back of my brain, I'm saying, I'm going to have to leave here because if I kill this man, everything that I stand for is going to go out the window.
But I can't stay here and allow them to do what they're doing. And the school was, I say, had racial problems from the president all the way down just above the jenus in the school, all the the maintenance people were black.
But they had the vibe that was so deep. And then at the same time, they didn't never experience individuals such as myself coming down there.
Like I said, I was my own man. They could dictate to me. I remember the coach telling me, say, John, whatever you do, don't talk to none of the white girls down here. And I remember telling them, I said, well, tell me, you tell me don't talk to the white girl. Well, what if the white girl come to talk to me? What do I do then? You tell me don't talk to him.
You know, I remember going to the Texas first indoor meet at like a cow palace, Dan Dallas. And I remember the browns, why they got, you know, sarcastic to me and start talking all kind of off the wall nonsense.
And I had to set up straight and tell her, say, you know, something's brown. I said, let me just say something, you know, the stakes that you have when you're playing tonight, you get them stakes and you're played as a result of what I'm doing.
So I said, let's not get this confused as to what my role is and what your role is. You used to tell them other kids that don't come tell me nothing like that. So right away, sharp eyes rolled back in their heads because she wasn't ready for the response that I gave her.
I was, no, it was dumb or brown. I had a situation where I'm running, I'm running everything doing the course of my time. They all attract me some winning and everything.
And I remember the, now Bobby, Bobby moral is a great sprinter, one in 1956, Olympics, 100 and 200. And he's out of the Abilene Christian.
And I might say a class guy, class act, much respectful Bobby moral. But don't my brown made a statement after I run and attract me. And he said, John Coloss is as great as Bobby moral.
And I guess Bobby at the time was, you know, like God's gift to Texas. And a lot of the people was offended that he said that a black man could be as great as Bobby moral.
And the next day he got a retracting statement. Yeah, you know, I looked at that and I said, oh, well, I see where he coming from. But towards the end of our relationship, we were getting ready to go to the, to the Lone Star conference.
As a fellow that I, I can say, I'll be friend of him. He'd be friend of me and made me comfortable with. I never fell about a name, but Terry Barnett White fellow.
I could go so far as to say Terry Barnett, I put Terry Barnett in the class of John Brown and Peter Norman. You know, he's a white guy that was on his own plane and had love for humanity.
And he came to me and he told me, he said, John, you see, I know things that's rough here, man. He said, but if you and I stay together, man, we can make a difference here.
And I liked what he said. And we became buddies. And we stayed there. And I remember when we was getting ready to go to the conference, like I said, I'd run everything, you know, just like Jesse Ones and Berlin, you know, run everything and you tied.
And we get ready to go to the conference meeting. And I walk in the locker room. And this is the day before we spoke to get in, and we didn't go in buses. We went in station wagons.
So he's got on the wall. He wants me to run a 350, then he want me to run a 280, then he want me to run on 150. And you know, for time.
So I'm looking at him. See, man, I'm not running. This is man. It's crazy. It's my boy. See, man, no, make no promise. Man, he's out. It's my I'm not running this. If he don't know that I'm capable of doing it now, why am I going to run this approach? I'm not doing it.
So we get out there. He got this stop. He's now come on, son. Come on. You know, you my house. I want you to run so and so. So when we started off for the 380. I'm on the turn and I took off running.
And I must have run maybe 60 yards and I stopped running and I walked and it was building a platform for the graduating class that he out in the stadium.
And I walk all the way around the track and I'm walking down and he walks down and he picks up a hammer. And he started walking towards me and tell me, nigga, I'm tired of you.
And I looked at him and I told him, I said, dummy, let me tell you something. I said, you better hope that that hammer is liquid because you come to me without making you eat it.
And I remember his son, Danny was on the wall and I said, Danny, I said, why don't you come down and take this ass working for your father.
And the son said, I'm not in that. I'm not involved in that.
But then I remember stripping down took my shorts, my job, everything I've right there in the field. The guys like they're playing football.
And at that time, if a black man dropped the football, they'd call them all kind of stupid this and stupid dad and the whole nine yards.
And a lot of them was caught in the quandary where I couldn't figure out why they was accepting this. I figured out later.
And that was because if they're in the left school that had been drafted before they could get into another school and they had been writing Vietnam.
And it took me a while to figure that one out. Why wouldn't you step up and say certain things? You know, they wouldn't do it.
So anyway, I took all my stuff and doing this face and I said, man, I'm done.
And I went inside and ripped my name off the locker, took all my stuff, took it over by the day. And I'm in the shower and he comes up in the shower and that son.
I might have been a little hasty and I'm looking at him and say, dumb, leave here.
Leave here because I was so mad, man, you go about to die in here. Just leave.
Now, I remember calling my wife and telling my wife, start packing, we leave it. My wife was working for this guy was the mayor of the town, but he was the chairman of the journalist department in the school too.
Now, my wife got the job with him. But incidentally, I might have my wife gave up a job. She was executive secretary for one of the generals over on Ellis Island.
So I don't think it was Ellis Island or another island over there. Anyway, she's general. So when we got down there, they promised all the job, you know, they can bust trips in the whole now.
We got to get rid of that. So when I said, look, y'all don't have nothing for my wife, I'm gone. But she got the job with this guy.
So I'm telling her, say, well, we leave it. So now I'm up in the student union, sitting out on the terrace and I'm telling all the guys, say, man, it's been a nice run. I love you guys. I said, but I'm getting ready to get out of here.
And they told me, what do you mean you get ready to go? So they had like a walkway and we up sitting on the balcony area and was like the vigilante committee. All the coaches, they didn't got together and they come in to walk up. John, we like to talk to you.
And I said, tell him, I said, yeah, well, okay, well, we like to take you lunch and head like a little cafeteria downstairs and that's doing you in the building. So I said, well, if you want to take me to feed me, all those guys together, you take all of us and feed all of us.
So they took them down, particularly like a pudding, did it. And they took me to a separate table. And they tell me, so a giant, you know, a dumb brown might have been hasting what he did. And he didn't mean this and he didn't mean that. And I said, no, he meant it.
I said, I meant what I said, too. And I'm getting up out of here and let you could do to tell me. And they left.
But my friend Terry, a boy, that came to me and Terry said to me, he said, John, he said, man, I know how you feel and I saw the answer that.
And he said, but man, you know, we made a commitment. We made a bond. And the bond was to win the long star championship. And he said, he said, he said, there's no way in the world that we would ever win this thing if you leave it.
And he said, man, I just hope that you would stay with the commitment that we made you and I made. And I told Terry, I said, Terry, that's the best thing I heard all year.
I said, yeah, you right. We're going to go and we're going to win the long star camp. We went, we won. Now when football team won, football team in that time was probably about 85 to 90 percent white.
When they won, they gave them these big, big ass rings. When we won the conference in track and field, they give us a little shoe with a flake. It wasn't even a dime as a flake.
And give it to them. I said, what's this? He said, well, listen, what you get for winning the conference. I said, no, man, I don't want that. I said, everybody on the track team deserve no less than what you get a football team.
Wait, not going to give you that. Oh, you're going to give it to me. I said, I'm telling you to give it to you. I'm telling you to give it to you. I said, I earned it. And everybody on this team earned it. So we eventually went and they gave the ring up.
And we still had the ring today. But it got so ridiculous down there, not just in commerce, but throughout Texas. I had a situation where I was in Austin, Texas, and I was with a reporter and the photographer, two white guys for the school.
And went into a bar to buy beer was hot day. Went into a bar and I had to go to the restroom and I told the bar, I said, bye, keep get these guys what they want. And I have a beer. I'm going to buy from the other guy come out. They drink it.
You know, beer for me. It was two Hispanic guys shooting pool. So I said, bye, keep with my beer. He just ignored me went on. So then I say, bye, keep a back for beer. He said, we don't serve niggas in here.
And I said, I don't ask for niggas for beer. And when he said something smart again, I reached across the kind of I grabbed him and I drug him and started dragging him over the kind of and the two Hispanic guys was playing pool. They rolled up and had to push things like bats to tell me, let him go.
And I'm backing out of there. But when I backed out of there, I wasn't concerned about the Hispanic guys. I wasn't concerned about the bot. And I was concerned about the two white guys that was with me. I said, man, I'm buying the food, the booze for you. And you going to drink and you ain't concerned about my business. You ain't heard y'all say boo.
So now I'm starting to look at them. And then it dawned on me. It escalated my brain. It wasn't even about them no more. It was about the fact that I was running all over the country with East Texas.
I'm not just representing East Texas State University. I'm representing the state of Texas. And here I'm in the state capital and I go to a bar and mainly because of the color of my skin, I have to be disrespected. And I can't be served.
Or we go on a bus and we go somewhere and we stop to eat. And the coach told me, well, you black guy is staring at the bus and the white kids, we're going to eat. Tell us what y'all want. And I have to step up and tell the coach, no, man, that's not the way I see it. If y'all going to the restaurant, we damn sure going to the restaurant.
So we don't go in the restaurant. You don't go in the restaurant. And he was like offended that I'm confronting them like this. But I'm looking at sitting on man, that's not. I don't know how it was yesterday, but this society is today.
So with these things, man, I had to go and I decided I got to leave East Texas. And I think it was really came to the clucks when he came in with that hammer because when he came with the hammer, I'm reflecting on what happened in Austin, Texas about the fact that I'm in the state capital.
And I'm representing the state of Texas and I can't even get a beer. So it all kind of mesh together this time for me to leave.
I left. I went back to New York and I was hoping my mother paint a kitchen in the farm rang. It was Professor Edwards. And he called me and told me, said, John, he says, uh,
some people having a very important meeting and they asked me to invite you. You think you can get away and ask my mother, say, mine, they got a meeting. They asked me where I come.
You think I can go and she said, yes, son, I can take care of the painting if they invite you to me, you need to be there.
And I remember going down to the Marricana Hotel, right across from the old garden. I went down there and I remember walking into the lobby. You know kids that grew up in New York, you know, all of
the way. We had to major mega hotels. I remember going into the hotel sitting in the lobby and looking at the chandeliers, the big pictures and mirrors. And I'm saying, man, I can get this chandelier, take it to my house.
Because my mother loved furniture. She was a perfection. My mother's a type of woman. She put plastic going to sofa. You can't sit on the fatigued. So same way.
So I shook that off and then I went to the desk and I asked for SCLC. I didn't know where that CLC was at the time, but I asked for it. And they told me, oh, yeah, go up so and so.
And I went up there and I knocked in the door. And I believe was Andrew Young that came in open the door. And I was in awe of Andrew Young because I envisioned Andrew Young as being like 6364.
And when I saw his statue, I was like in shock. And I'm thinking to myself all that time, I said, God, the guy that was shooting this picture must have been landed in the back and just shooting everything up because he looked so tall.
But he was called you. He was nice. He invited me in. She's like soda, juice, water, milk, sandwich, cookies, you know. And I'm sitting there. And I'm just, you know, looking at these people and just think that I'm watching these people as a kid on TV and him. I'm in a room with him.
But like I said earlier, I never put the dots together. He even faffish in my mind that Dr. King was in that room or that he was going to come to that room.
And I said like 20 minutes later, he opened up a back bedroom door and he walked out there, man. And I was 50 feet tall. First thing I thought is, man, my mother need to be a rock in my pocket of bug on my lapel. She needs to be here right now.
And I remember when I got home and I told my mother what happened. My mother said to me, see what son I was there. I was dead through you. You know, it was just heavy.
But I asked Dr. King about him. Did he play any sports? And he said, no, I can't shoot pool. And I asked him, I said to him, I said, with Dr. King, why would you, why would you get involved in the Olympic Project for Human Rights?
And he said to me, he said, Don, he said, that's a good question. And he says to me, he says, he said, imagine you being in a lake and you take the roadboat and you roll out to the center of the lake.
And then you bring the oars in, you sit there and you be still and everything is still in serene. He said, you reach down, you pick up a rock and you reach over and you drop that rock. What happens?
And I said, it creates vibrations. He smiled. He said, yes, it creates waves. He said, well, that rock is that Olympic boycott. He said, now it will arouse anything in that lake.
And anything on the shore of that lake to let you know that something is a miss. He said, that's the Olympic boycott. He said, and the greatest thing about it is that you will wake the world up in a very nonviolent way.
That carried me over to Mexico in terms of that demonstration. I want to do something that would be so powerful that would reach the ends of the earth and yet still be nonviolent.
Yeah, we didn't have no father overtones whatsoever. And the second thing I asked him, I said to him, I said, Dr. King, I said, you said if you come back from Memphis and you told us in your speech in the meeting that they threaten your life.
They sent you a letter to tell you to add a bullet with your name when you went into the way long. And they threaten your life. Why would you go back to Memphis?
And he looked at me and when he looked at me, I used to have shades on dark shades. I still wear dark shades a lot of times. But I took my glasses and put them on my nose so I could look dead into his eyes. I don't know glass from what I'm going to see his eyes.
I'm looking for fear. When a man tells you that somebody told them they're going to kill him, you're supposed to see a little shaky dance. The rocket you brought to him and I ain't she number loving a man's eyes for society.
He said to me, he said, John, he said to me, he said, that's a better question than last one. He said, but you know, I have to go back to Memphis and stand for those that won't stand for themselves and stand for those that can't stand for themselves.
And when he said that to me, my whole life came full circle because all the things that I've been doing in my life was the same thing. I just never had a phrase or title or caption I could put on it. But he just lit me up when he made that one statement. I had to go and stand for those that won't stand and those that can't stand.
That's the clutch of it. Let me know that his life was second, the past day. He said to me, he said, they can kill me, but they can never kill me. In other words, I would be greater in depth than I am in life for what I stand for. And I'll tell people, I said, you know, Dr. King lost his flesh, but his spirit and his meaning and his energy and his vision will live for eternity.
How many people can say that when I leave here, they'll remember what I stood for. Say not a whole bunch of people that's going to get that life. And I go back and I'll tell you, I say, you know, when you sit back and you think about what he told me, it began to think about the fact that, you know, they got like John Wayne, Liz Taylor, Rock Hudson, all these luminaries that they had in the entertainment field, whether it's music, or whatever.
But when they die, they're gone. But you sit back and you look at Paul Robinson, they talk about him every day, Rosa Parks, they talk about her every day, Harriet Tubman, every day, Gandhi, every day, Tommy Smith, every day, Peter Norman, every day. So it began to make you think.
Nelson Mandela, every day, they'll be talking about him.
Okay. Based on the fact that these individuals that I said, the movie star, they were man made icons and these other individuals are God giving icons. And that's the big difference.
Why doesn't that they remember them, but they don't talk about John Wayne? Well, that's the thing you heard them talk about Liz Taylor.
You understand? But I hear them talking about Rosa Parks all the time. And people have to start looking at these things and trying to have someone to stand and you're like, everybody got them voids in their life. Like I told you I experienced when I was a kid.
The difference is I was trying to fill a voice. A lot of people are still running around in the corner. You don't understand the package. They can't put the package together in their head.
That's why a lot of people don't stand for anything other than the dollar because they think the dollar is their God.
So at the time of that, you had already qualified for the Olympic Games at the time of that meeting? For the Olympic team? No. No. What it was a good bet that you would.
Well, it was a question. So, what we want to go. You know, if I was healthy, it was nowhere in the world. Everybody can beat me to stop me from making the team.
You know, when I went to the games, I didn't go to the game for the medal. You know, by the time I decided I was going to the game, the reason why I went to the games opposed to staying home like Karim Karim.
And I had a conversation one time and I told Karim, I said, man, you're the NBA. If you choose not to go to the games, you say I prefer to stay home for my studies. Who's going to question that?
I said, but me, if I stay home from the games, man, what they're going to do is find somebody who's just capable because America was the number one strength track and field nation in the world.
So if I chose not to go, someone else is going to get in my place and go. But the difference was, would they represent John Carlson, where he felt he needed to be represented on that victory stand?
That's the main reason why I went. It wasn't about no medal. Only medal consciousness that I had is that I had to win any medal.
To get on the victory stand, I didn't go there anticipating taking third. I was giving the medal to Tommy. But see, that's what God steps in.
But God put Peter Norman there to make this thing solidified and stand. We got 50 million white people running on the planet.
Out of 50 million white people, I don't think we found two to mass Peter Norman.
Peter Norman was the Australian. He took the silver. That's right.
So God's in the right there. Anybody could have won that silver medal of white, ethnic background. But anybody wouldn't have had the audacity as Peter Norman.
Can you talk a little bit so you would decided not to do the boycott. King had been assassinated.
And you did decide to go participate in the games. When did you start to form this idea of making a statement at the games and how did Peter Norman get in?
Well, we decided that we was going to do something, we thought that we would do it in the sense of this boycott. But when the boycott was resolved or dissolved, it was a matter of me standing at Tommy.
I'm disenchanted that the fact that the boycott was called off and I want to make a statement. And that was at the end of the quarter semi.
That's when we came together and started putting together the terms of all the facts that we was going to bring out.
And then we roughly had 25 minutes before we went out there to figure out exactly what we was going to do and how we was going to do it.
Nobody knew who was going to do. Peter didn't know who was going to do it until we started dealing with it in front of him.
And I asked Peter, I said, man, do you believe in human rights? And that's when Peter began to tell me about his mom and his dad was salvation.
I mean, working all of his life. Of course, I believe in human rights. I said, would you like to wear the Olympic project for human rights button?
And he said, I said, he started reaching for my own. I had to pat him on his hand. Get back. I'll get you one.
And then we had some white guys from Harvard University, Rose. And one of them was Paul. And I asked Paul to throw down a button to me.
And he's looking at me like, you got a button. I'm going to tell him to say it's for Peter.
And he took the button and he threw it down. And I pinned it on Peter just before we walked out there.
And that's how Peter had the Olympic project for human rights button. But it was deeper than him having the button.
It was the conviction that he had. That's why I said, Peter, you know, in our trials and tribulations and his trials and tribulations, all they told Peter,
said, man, all you have to do is denounce those guys. Peter never flinched. He never backed away. He never denounced us. He never turned his back on us.
He stood fast. That's why I said when Peter died, say if I had to walk to Australia from the United States, I'd have got to walk him right away.
Because I was not going to miss his service, miss being there for him and his demise.
I mean, one of the greatest human beings of all time. That's why I put Peter down with John Brown.
That's that. That's why I put Terry Ames, Terry Burnett down with John Brown.
Because these are white individuals that rose above the norm. They knew about repercussions at that time.
But they weren't concerned about repercussions. They was there because it was the right thing to do.
But you see, back you say they don't talk about John Brown. They don't talk about Robin Hood. They don't talk about Terry Burnett.
You understand? They don't talk about Peter Norman. You don't have to people in the United States around the world don't know the suffering that Peter Norman had to go through.
Peter didn't raise his fists. Peter didn't disrespect his nation's flag.
All Peter Deere was put on a button and say, I commend these individuals enough that I would want to be in support of these individuals.
And let me tell you the character Peter Norman. They built some statues that sound as they state.
And when they started building those statues, I got a call and somebody told me, they said, John, you didn't build a statue.
They got you and Tommy and Peter's not there. I jumped in my car and I drove the sound as they from LA.
I went there and I said to him, I said, what's the deal here? Peter, y'all didn't put Peter up. I don't want my statue going there.
I don't want to be a part of this. And they said, well, John, we mean you don't be a part of it.
I said, well, why is Peter not there? So, John, it's the students that raised the money for this.
I said, I know the students raised the money for this.
They said, but Tommy Smith, and you went to school here, Peter didn't go to school here.
I said, it's irrelevant about what he went to school here. It's about the energy and the effort.
In the meeting behind what we did about which school he went to.
And then when I'm stepped up and say, well, Peter didn't want to be there.
I left them and I went to the president, Dr. Tassel at the time.
And I said, it's a done. I said, I need to make a call. He said, make a call.
I said, I need to call Peter Norman in Australia. Just by heart, man, I call.
He picks up the phone. And he said, who's this? He said, it's Carlos.
He said, you know, he's blaming his Carlos. He didn't even put his accent on me. It's Australian accent.
And I said, Peter, I have a question here. He said, what is it?
I said, tell my son, man, you don't want to be a part of the statue?
He laughed. He said, John, I would love to be a part of the statue.
He said, but let me tell you the way I see it. And I said, let me hear the way you see it.
Because anyway, you can tell me that you shouldn't be there. And he said to me, he said, listen.
He said, I didn't do what you guys did. He said, I support you with you guys did.
I support you then. I support you now. And I will always support you.
He said, I think it's only fair and I propose that I not have my statue there.
So when people come from a world, the world that come to that school,
they can take their picture standing in my spot and support you guys did.
Now, let me tell you something. I'm going to say this right now loud and clear.
I love Tommy Smith, but I don't think Tommy Smith would have ever did with Peter Norman, did in that sense.
That's a man's man to say, man, I put the world before I put myself.
And that's what it's all about, man, the sacrifice you yourself for the world.
That's what Jesus Christ did. You sit back and you think about, you know,
I think about New York here when I came through, when I broke the world record at the trials.
John Coles, I own New York. John Coles, great.
30 days later after the demonstration, same paper. John Coles, neighborhood bum.
My father in the hospital died and he got tears in his eyes.
Why did you do those bad things based on their headlines in the paper?
But you know, I said to my father, I said, pop, read the paper.
I said, you don't know rap brown. You don't know Stoke because my,
you don't know my fests. And you don't know Tommy. Do you know John Coles?
Yes, son. I know. I said, well, the same thing they saying about those individuals,
they saying about me. Nobody knows John Coles on this planet better than you.
My father started crying. I started crying. Just like my father embraced me when I
told my head that vision, I embraced him. And I was hugging my father and tears running
down my eyes, tears running down my eyes. And I'm saying, man, if they can bamboozle my
father, I can imagine what they're doing to just the grassroots people in society.
But you sit back and you think about the fact that they call me a trouble maker.
That's a heavy word, a trouble maker. But then, you know, I heard that word so many times
until I began to look at that word and evaluate that word, turning up sound,
turning over. And then I started seeing visions after that. And you know what I found?
I found Gandhi for the trouble maker. I found Martin Luther King, a trouble maker.
I found Paul Roberson, a trouble maker. I found Nelson Mandela, a trouble maker.
I found Jesus Christ, a trouble maker. But I found at the same time that John Coles
and damn good company to be a trouble maker with those individuals. Because those are
the true fighters for society. All of us are called trouble makers.
Okay, we're back.
Let me just go.
If you could, you started to talk a little bit about going out to actually do the demonstration.
But can you walk us through that? I mean, when you first said, okay, we're going to do something.
And we're putting together what you had with you and what symbols and what they meant.
Could you sort of describe that and what it felt like when you went out there and then what it felt like actually on the podium?
All right. Well, the first thing relative to the symbols is some of the time that I had discussion at the end of the quarter of the century.
When we decided that jointly, we wanted to do something to make a statement.
You know, boycott is over, but we felt very strong. We had a strong conviction that something needed to be said.
And we came to conclusion that by making a statement, we had to bring symbols to solidify the statement.
He started talking about some clubs, bringing the clubs. I had a black shirt that cover up my USA jersey merely because I was ashamed of America.
For all of America's history relative to people of color or society, I was ashamed of it.
So I want to cover up my USA with that jersey.
Tommy had a black scarf for all the sacrifice of black people in the land.
I had bees. I wore the bees just for the simple reason that there were so many black people that were lynched throughout the South for years upon years.
I was heading bees on for those that were stone overboard and the main voyage and those that were stone off of the island over there.
And Africa took the sharks that no one ever said a prayer for. These are the symbols.
We took the poor machine out there merely because I represented the poor people.
And what like a did is you had to be a superstar to get somebody to just pull my shoes if you was poor and couldn't afford it, that would give me to you.
I saw that they gave too. So I wanted to be a part of that. That's why I took my shoe out there and had time to take this and put it out there.
And you were in your socks too, weren't you?
The me of water black socks with no shoes to illustrate poverty and people were still walking back and forth 20 miles to get to him from school.
Didn't have no transportation. And yet and still we still talking about them going to the moon, the land of spaceship a half mile from where they said they're going to land it.
But they tell me they can't stop a cockroach or they can't stop a rat from meeting kids and they get up.
So all of these things was culminated to make a statement and then the glove.
In my estimation, the glove everybody talked about the glove and the fist.
Well before there was a fist, there was five people, five continents, people of color.
What I'm jumping down is a man. If I can move this pebble across the road, I can make it a significant difference in society.
But he jumped down, he tried moving, he can't move it.
Another guy said, man, I saw what you did wrong. He didn't put your hips into it.
He jumped down, he tried, he can't do it.
But eventually they came to conclusion that we all put our minds together and put our bodies into it.
And when people come together, that becomes a very powerful force.
That's what that was about. It wasn't about destruction and turn America down, blowing up the statual liberty.
We were just letting them know that we are powerful force, not just merely on the track but in society.
And you're going to have to accept us as being a part of society.
Here's a statement I made when I was 23 years old.
About the fact that they are trying to hold us down like we five steps below the ladder.
And every time we try and reach up to pull ourselves up, they step on our hands and don't want us to climb up.
They don't need more than to pull ourselves up. We're going to ask you to give us anything.
And we said open up the door like James Brown said and we'll get it ourselves.
But you don't even want us to touch the door.
So that's it. And enough, y'all. We went out there. We went out to the victory stand.
You know, the first thing I thought about when I went out there was that vision because the same way that those people responded when we raised our hands was the same way they responded in that vision.
The second thing I thought of was my father telling about the quest that he had when he was in the first world war when the war was integrated, segregated and had the white sergeants and lieutenants and so forth.
They came in to lead the black troops. I thought about how he talked about what was for a black man after they served in the war to come home and how they were treated.
I thought about my days there. He's Texas State. I thought about my era in New York and the Harlem in terms of how they dropped the drugs on Harlem to solidify what I was doing in my mind to make me sound and know that what I was doing was the right thing.
And when it all culminated with everything was said and done.
My last thing that went through me was they could never ever put shackles on John Carlos again. They will never ever incarcerate me in my mind or as they say to a chain me to the ball.
I'm a free man. And if I had to lose my life as a result of that. Well, so big. I'm ready to die. I'm a die anyway.
But I prefer dying with a smile on my face to the die with agony and turmoil and know that I never did anything about it.
So what was the response right then in the stadium and then how did that sort of snowball?
It was a double-edged race because the people that was there from the country of Africa or any third world country, specifically those people there of Mexico, they had a tragedy that had taken place in Mexico 10 days before the team started coming in.
When they'd gun down, you know, my estimation was like close to 2000 students. They just gunned them down in the square.
And they told them say, yeah, just hand the old business and get them people out the way in the United States team to come.
That's like saying open up the guns on them. Do what you have to do. They took those individuals bodies and throw them in the furnace until they couldn't put no more in the furnace.
Then they got the National Guard and get the National Guard ships to come in and take them out to the ocean and dump the rest of the bodies in the ocean.
And the skies, let's get the games, let's have the games going. And then one time they took what 50 people died. Then there was 150 people died.
Now they took about 1,500 people died. It was close to the 2,300 people and my estimation had lost their lives as a result of this.
So, you know, you had to have justification in yourself. It's circumvent your mind to make sure that you're not making a fool of yourself.
You're not making a mockery of what you're doing. Yeah, a question is going to come to us. Names are going to come at us.
They're going to try and do everything to put us down to make us look crazy in the whole nine yards.
We had to stand fast and have the answers when they started shooting them. They didn't like the answers that we was giving them. But they could not deny the answer that we was giving them out.
Did you have supporters? Yeah, my mom, my dad and my brother and sister. You're my family supporting me. And my God supporting me. I didn't need no more support of that.
You know, a lot of people loved what we did. But the power is to be those that was in power and had some weight that could have did certain things.
Now, you know, nobody pick up and say, let me send them a dime because I know they ain't better to feed their kids. They can't get milked to feed their kids.
And nobody's supporters in that sense to think about my man after they did that, we know it's going to be terribly hard. Anybody sent us a dime.
But years later, one of my biggest supporters and one of my dearest friends before doing and years later after was George Foreman.
They tried and put it divided because George weighed the American flag and ran around and they tried making like, I hate George.
George hate me for what I stood for. And I was so far from the truth. So far from the truth.
But at the same time, when you should back and think back in 1968, all that hair was the right wing press.
It wasn't a liberal press for me to go and talk about what I thought about George. I ain't never knocked George's wing.
I couldn't wave the flag. I wish I could wave the flag. But it wasn't a flag waving opportunity for me.
I loved to wave the flag. But at the same time, and all of the way to wave the flag, they have to let me accept them as I did.
And they have to accept me as they should have. They didn't accept people of color.
And right now, when you sit back and you look at the Republicans, what the way they're doing things right now, it's almost like they tell you,
say, yeah, man, everything that went down in the 60s that you fought for, that everybody felt like they comfortable with, they taken it back.
I mean, everything that is out there right now, we put a black man in the White House, probably one of the most brilliant men that ever walked the halls in the White House.
And they try to do everything they can to slap him down. And to all those blacks that might not like Barack, for what Barack does, they don't understand the mechanisms of the White House.
They don't understand for a black man to go in the White House. It takes him the first four years just to find a key to the private bathroom, much more anything else in terms of trying to get legislation done.
And my father's always telling me, and I put this out to anybody that want to go public against Barack and tell him, say, my old man, you should tell me, say, if you don't have nothing good to say, don't say nothing.
And that's a lesson that a lot of people should learn, because they ain't doing them but shooting themselves in the foot when they're trying to nonsermen, that's going through hell and high water to make this a better society.
So if I can ask how that, so how did that moment in Mexico City resonate in the years that followed for you and for Peter and for Tommy?
Well, it just became a beacon for society. And y'all don't think that it holds up at any ethnic group. And in his country, people resonated around that demonstration.
In your country, people resonated around that demonstration in Cuba and Africa and Asia and anywhere on this planet, there's people that resonated around that particular demonstration because they know what depression is about.
They know this demonstration was for people to be treated as human beings to be civil amongst one another to give everybody the same opportunity that you want for your kids.
So everybody gravitated to it. You know, white people had indifference as it's true. Where they had slave reworked whites enslaved their own people. They don't want to talk about it, but it was there.
And people can still, when you sit back right now, you go to anywhere, you go to Italy, you go to Greece, you go anywhere, they still going to change that they related. It ain't just black people. This is the universal thing. See, they try and make it like it was a black thing.
And they forget what that button said that we want our chest and says a little bit projects for human rights. That's for humanity. It wasn't for me.
And that's the way it still stands today. It resonates throughout the world. Any Olympics that go to what I'm there in the flesh, it doesn't matter because I'm there just based on my energy.
I can live with that. I don't have to go to the Olympics because a lot of kids, Jefferson and Scott, you know, everywhere you still sit in your liberal, but you at the Olympics and in Munich, you at the Olympics games over there in Australia.
Somebody called me and told me, man, you know, you didn't come to the games. You said, but you know, they got an 80 foot wall, which you were in that wall. And everybody that goes into that stadium and everybody leaves that state of my everybody drives by on the train, see that 80 foot picture of you.
People stop and then take pictures of it and send those they stay people coming from all around the world. They would never go to send those they stay. They come to send those they just to go through that camp, just stand in and take that picture.
So yeah, I'm very pleased with the fact that God picked that little grain of sand up through it on the kind of say, Johnny, you could be involved in this. I ain't putting no pressure on yours. Your decisions to what you want to do or not because we all have choices in life.
But there was an arc to it too, right? Where that, I mean, that powerful moment kept resonating and kept men, but sort of came back. But there were you all paid some prices for having done that as well.
I'm going to talk about the prices. Only only thing that I would say that I regret in the whole scenario is the fact that I was young. And I didn't think the thing all the way through in terms of how to protect my family better.
Other than that, I had no misgivers whatsoever. You know, it's a hurting thing for me to even sit here and just think the fact that my wife, my first wife couldn't take it and took her life.
It was a hurting thing for my kids to have to endure that. It was a hurting thing for my kids to have to sacrifice in school merely because I was their father. It was a hurting thing for me not to be able to give my kids a Christmas for many years just based on my beliefs.
But at the same time, when in all the dust settled, I said, my kid would have had to go to a thousand no Christmas's. My wife would have had to kill herself a thousand times because what I did in Mexico City would far greater than in her life, my life or anything that ever happened to my kids because it ain't about me. It's about all of us.
And that's the end. That's it. You know, ain't worried about the bad things that happen to me. I remember when I used to do certain things and my father then particularly cared for it. He would tell me, say, son, you got $40. You got $40. I was to make me understand what you did and why you did it.
Now, if he didn't agree with what I said, he got that ass so bit, get the ass. But I believe in what I did and I'm going to get out tomorrow and do it again because I believe that I'm right. And about that you want to whip me and that's what America wants to do. America wants to tap on this ass because they didn't agree with what I did.
But I didn't worried about them tap, tap on this ass. I'm worried about when they come to realization that you know them.
All the thick and thin when all of us settle, we can't get around the fact that those 200 victims were right. You know, you know, I did this man to sit back in your old age.
And remember, when I was gotten involved in this thing, I was 23 years old. But the sit back in your old age and everything become crystallized in your mind and you start to realize,
you're man, you did something that only one other person on planet earth. Before your life, during your life, I even asked your life can actually say that they did this. Just told people on the planet.
That's a heavy thing, man. And then to realize that it was for the betterment of mankind.
Let me ask you too, because I know there's, it did resonate obviously and did affect lots of people. But then you also had another part of your life where you were affecting people one on one and that's as a teacher.
And I know there was a, maybe you had some trouble learning and living at first and then, and then ended up being a high school teacher.
I always taught, I taught individuals because when I was a kid, I learned from older individuals. And I always felt like the best way to communicate with a kid is to melt that kid down and become part of that kid.
And then, standing like two candles melting and blending together. And that way a kid can feel good about learning something. And you know, and they said, man, it's something about you long time before they knew who you were. Like, friends, that, that a fear that I went to last night.
I had so many youngsters that was there when I was out there doing my thing.
What was the event last night? This was a, it was the New York City first annual reunion for all traction field athletes. They ran for the PSL and, and the schools in New York.
And so many of those individuals that come to me and tell me about things I did to them and did for them and showed them and took the time with them. And then the bottom line was for them to tell me, say, man, when you came to me, you was like a idol.
And then, when you came to me, you were like, you was over me. You came to me like, you was a part of me. You know, you made me feel good. You made me feel happy that you took the time.
You would come and see me run a race and then come over and tell me, man, you need to do this. You need to do that. And it's going to help you. And then realize at the same time, how quick it helped me.
It helped me down the line and helped me immediately. And for me to hear, people say that it's just like what you said about how you resonated to people one on one. That's been all my life. That's a part of me.
You know, I feel good that I'm doing that. And yesterday, I would say, it's probably the one that most profound times in my life because I don't really get a chance to hear people tell me what I did at high, touch the light.
But I heard it in abundance last night. You know, and I left here with a feeling that everything that God showed me and told me that vision and my life is coming to truth. Even to that point last night.
Time for me to take a break too.
In terms of what I had in the second place, I don't want to scare.
Well, I'm not scared, but they don't realize that part of history. And I think it's important.
Okay.
I'm fine if you don't ask.
Whatever you're, yeah.
You know, the biggest sacrifice is losing your loved one. That's the biggest sacrifice. And that's an emotional sacrifice.
You know, sometimes, you know, people ask me that question is half me, even all this time.
Later, it's hard to talk about it. You know, so, you know, I'm relative to what happened in those areas. I prefer to let them lay because it doesn't really matter.
You know, about what they did to me. It's what matters to me is where we came from that. Where we headed. That's the important thing to me.
The sacrifice for me, you said, man, God sacrificed. For a road sense, everybody sacrificed to make, you know, everybody noted they were sacrificing Bob.
In terms of personal sacrifice, that's irrelevant. The initial thing is, I gave my all to make better for those that come after me.
That's the most important thing. If they, anybody think that, you know, they did something and they was rewarded for it or they wasn't punished for it or they wouldn't put down for it, they're mistaken.
I mean, they don't have a clue as to what part they in much more, you know, where they are in space and time.
I mean, you said back, I remember if I looked at something that was painful, I had two individuals that grew up with me in the sport.
I needed to note in individual Olympians. And I remember one day sitting at the airport with these two guys and watching the DC and we were waiting on the plane about three or four o'clock in the morning.
And I remember them leaning across the table and telling me, man, you really screwed up your life. You know, you screwed up your life so bad, they ain't gonna never let you work in America.
Your kids gonna go through hell. You ain't gonna never find a job. You really screwed up. And they went so far to say, man, I don't even know what I feel kind of was sitting here with you right now.
And these guys that I grew up with and I looked at them and I said, tell them, let me tell you something, man.
I see you haven't seen a Humm and Bird. I said, Humm and Bird. And then he just stops. I said, that's me.
I see you see somebody fall off a bridge and they don't go down. They train water. I said, that's me. I said, man, I didn't go down. I just stopped.
And I said, now you think you're up here? I said, I was up there. I said, let me tell you this. I'm a rise again. And when I rise, I just pray that I remember to be me and be humble and never disguised myself to be like you guys.
And I remember this guy had a big golf tournament every year. He didn't even fight all of you. He would never invite me.
But when I start rising again, I get a call. Hey, I'll be done. Oh, Doug, you are one cemetery that they think you have to call me.
So everybody that tried and put me down in my life, you know, they've all come back knocking because now they want to be in the picture.
Now they want that brick. And I tell them, I said, man, I love you less than yesterday and more than yesterday and less than tomorrow.
But I can't change history. And I will never attempt to change history. If you was in the picture, then you in the picture.
But if you wasn't in the picture, I can't put you in the picture now because you ever change your heart 40 years later because things look like it's sunny on my side of the street now.
So, you know, to talk about things like, you know, the negatives, I would have to talk about those people as well. I don't want to talk about that.
I don't want to talk about, you know, pain that I had to deal with to see my kids suffer. I don't want to talk about, you know, the fact that you had to go to welfare and try and get some sort of assistance doing Christmas just to have one kid under a tree for your kid during Christmas time.
You know, I don't want to talk about the meh effect that I never had groceries in my house at one time and thank God I had one partner named Ron Freeman at Canaan Miles.
Didn't say a word. Just look and sort. And the next, you know, he come back miles two hours later with bags of groceries.
Things like that I never forget. And where am I going like? They always go with me. But for me to get up and talk about it.
That's not what I want. What I want to talk about, man, is how we can still come together and make this a better place for our children, our children's children. That's the most important thing, you know.
Psychophys is going to go everywhere. Everybody that did something in society, psychophysied. You think about John Brown, but all he did fight against all odds. You think John Brown didn't know that he was going to die? And you think he didn't know that he was going to die for people that wasn't even of his race?
He knew about the psychophys of his life. You think Dr. King didn't know that he was going to die? God didn't know he was going to die?
On Malcolm didn't know he was going to die. All of them knew they was going to die. But it didn't deter them. They weren't concerned about the psychophys.
And some of them, like I said, made the ultimate sacrifice, but it didn't stop. But they were. They ain't, I'm just checking it.
I don't want to do it because I might die. Forget that. Let's talk about what comes from psychophys, from the hurt.
I got days where I stayed in the dark man and had tears rolled down my eyes. But at the same time I got days where I smiled and the sun has tears rolled down my eyes for happiness as well.
I think we've hit it right there.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.